ether ray has joined us at the table she
was nominated for an Emmy and two Golden
Globes for her starring role in the
critically acclaimed HBO series it is so
good insecure
she's also the show's creator and
executive producer thank you very much
in her new movie little it's called
little Issa Rae portrays April the
assistant to a demanding tech mogul when
April's boss wakes up as her 13 year old
self betrayed by a blackish star
marseilles Martin April has to cover for
her you know does that have to be you I
should probably just apart and borrow
some of your clothes your body convinced
my clothes this squats
this is Pilates that body looks like
Baby Gap Gymboree ass gospel gosh to be
said earlier is at the table I want to
talk about the movie because the movies
knockout I saw it three years ago but I
want to start with Nipsey Hussle if we
could today because I know that you all
came from the same area and I want you
to talk about what he means why this is
such a big loss yes a huge devastating
loss because he was one of the few
people who so much about his community
and so much about empowering and
prioritizing and making sure to reinvest
in the community by giving us black
businesses his store investment coffee
shops he was just really passionate
about making sure that this remained
ours he was anti gentrification and
cared about us when nobody else did and
it was just such a tragedy to lose him
because he just had so many so many
goals and was so respected as you can
see from the outpouring of and you know
it's it was it's a true tragedy I know I
saw your tweet about him and he was the
day yesterday he was scheduled to meet
with police about gang related issues he
had talked about being a former gang
member and they still had that meeting
and and I thought this was something
different in the community they are
calling on people come forward and let's
find this man who took his life normally
there's a
don't don't tell don't say that's
different this time absolutely because
people want justice they want justice to
be served like everyone's feeling this
loss tremendously so I mean I don't
blame them you know alrighty so right
we are glad you're here so many things
to talk about insecure but let's talk
about little because the producer said
this about you I don't think there's
anyone else who could deliver lines and
throw shade no shade in the nonchalant
way nonchalant way that she does one of
the film's producers what is your tiny
sperm is impeccably our timings impact
sounds like he or she said I was Sadie
but that's throwing shake late to April
at all what did you enjoy about playing
her I enjoyed playing April because well
I haven't had been in that position for
so long like a you know I have a
position I mean I haven't been someone's
assistant of their a lot of time that's
true and to be to play Regina halls
assistant who's just so hilarious yeah
and take her abuse was fun and then to
take my phase abuses a lot of fun but it
was just I definitely struggled with
finding my voice and being able to speak
up for myself and so to be able to
internalize that kind of again with
April and then find a journey to find
her voice was a pleasure to play when
that's part of what the movies about
just finding your voice what how does
one find their voice and what can I do
[Laughter]
doing quite well with your voice I mean
it takes confidence I think it takes a
sense of knowing what you want to say
and I think April throughout the movie
just really wants to be promoted she has
this wonderful idea and she's scared of
rejection she's scared of this verbal
abuse but sometimes as women in the
workplace you really just have to to
speak up for yourself and not expect to
be rewarded automatically well can you
use comedy essentially deal with the
fact that her boss is a bully yeah
absolutely I think comedy is just you
know as you've seen some nights it's
just it the easiest medicine to feed
people just like oh okay like if for
example if you tell someone you're
racist outright they'll be like how dare
you that's not true
but if
you couch it in the jokes they be like
yeah I am so happy for your success Issa
and insecure I remember when the show
was first starting and because you said
listen it started off as a blog of the
adventures of an awkward black girl and
here you are awkward black girl no more
yeah on the cover of essence magazine
you could say that I'm still awkward
black girl thank you
I still let you look at your background
you think you went from an all-white
school to an all-black school and trying
to fit in in both places cover of
essence beautiful I mean thank you guys
that's just an intern nobody can tell
you what you feel inside definitely I
have confidence for sure I'm not I hear
feeling sorry for myself but you know
you just feel uncomfortable in certain
situations I will always identify as an
awkward black girl no matter what
happens no matter well how did you feel
awkward because I was a little jealous
when you're in the video with [ __ ] with
with Rosie my Drizzy i call him also
known as Drake yeah yeah you know the
last time I was on this show you showed
me text from him and it made me jealous
so I'm so glad that I could return it
was just not gonna be in his videos I
know don't have a shot just go some of
us out of being in video come on yes
without a dad I'm sure well now that you
know maybe you could put in a good word
somebody she can do anything that Gayle
King continued success - I know
congratulations - oh she said Nora that
you would never do another show where
you play the title character I where I'm
also I created British oh my god getting
jobs yourself and blocking yours
go now thank you very much
mommy you come back in each other
open theatres April 12